what comes to mind when you hear the
words Napoleon Bonaparte Emperor of
France we're guessing it's a certain
petite copper in a big on hat rearing up
majestically on a horse as he conquers
half of Europe but what if we told you
there was another Emperor Napoleon
Bonaparte Bonaparte II not only managed
to rule France for longer than his
famous predecessor but basically created
modern Paris well today you're gonna
meet that man Louie Napoleon Bonaparte
aka Napoleon the third he was the actual
nephew of Napoleon as a child he was
forced to watch the French Empire
collapse and see his family driven into
hiding as an adult he single-handedly
returns the Empire from ruin and then
ruled it for 22 years he's the man who
created modern Paris the politician who
made France great again and the general
who led his nation into a ruinous war
Napoleon the third he was certainly all
of these things and many more and in the
video today the story of history's
forgotten Bonaparte on March the 20th
1811 cannons boomed out across Paris
revelers gathered outside the Twinner
ease Paris it was official Emperor
Napoleon had a son had he been old
enough to understand the news
three-year-old Shar Louie Napoleon
Bonaparte mayor felt sadness born on
April the 20th 1808 the boy was the
youngest son of Louis Bonaparte brother
of the Emperor and Queen Hortense of
Holland's who just to gross you out a
little was also nuit Bonaparte's niece
more important than his parents creepy
relationship though was that Louie
Napoleon was a potential heir to the
imperial crown along with his older
brother
Napoleon Louie and no I didn't screw
that up Louie de Polian the star of our
story had an older brother called
Napoleon Louie apparently they thought
that just weren't enough French guys
running around with the name Napoleon
it's pretty good well maybe we should
just say that he had been an heir prior
to that March day in 1811 Emperor
Napoleon he had no legitimate son to
inherit the crown now though he no
longer had any need for his nephews this
was tragic not just from the perspective
of Louie
Napoleon not being Emperor but also
because producing new Bonaparte's was
the only reason his parents were married
Louie and Hortense they totally hated
one another by 1810 they couldn't even
live in the same country pretends had
taken the boys to Paris while Louie
remains in Holland not that young Louie
Napoleon saw much of his famous uncle in
the French capital no longer a likely
heir he spent the early 1810 simply
hanging around waiting for his newborn
cousin to supplant him as the future
Emperor and for that to happen he did
not have to wait very long in 1812
Emperor Napoleon made the really stupid
mistake of invading Russia barely 18
months later the French Empire it was in
ruins and Paris was under Allied
occupation realizing that the jig was up
a desperate to save his dynasty Napoleon
abdicated and made his three-year-old
son Emperor Napoleon ii on April the 4th
1814 but it was at this point that the
occupying allies were pretty much like
that's not happenin and forced the
entire Bonaparte line to abdicate two
days later on April the 6th before
handing young napoleon ii over to
austria if you started this video
thinking Napoleon the third what about
Napoleon the second where did he go well
he went to Austria that's white there's
not really a video about him in the
aftermath of water Li the entire
Bonaparte clan it was forced into exile
Louie Napoleon and his family they
resettle in Switzerland where they could
do nothing but watch as France abolished
its empire and restored the monarchy it
could have been a crushing psychological
blow if it were not for Queen Hortense
from the moment they reached exile
Hortense started grooming Louie Napoleon
and his brother to become future
emperors now this was an absurd thing to
do but it would also turn out to totally
be the right move on May the 5th 1821
the ProLiant Bonaparte died in exile on
sent Hellena
about him Europe the news made all the
great powers suddenly super nervous
about young napoleon ii so worried were
they about this child prisoner taking
his father's mantle that they completely
overlooked louie napoleon no one noticed
as he and his brother moved to Italy's
papal States in 1826 no one noticed as
they joined the Carbonari Lodge and
started training in revolutionary
warfare like an audience watching a
magic trick Europe's great powers were
too busy looking at the wrong Napoleon
by the time they realized their mistake
it was too late on July the 22nd
18:32 Napoleon the second quarter
pneumonia in Austria and he died at age
21 when the news hit all surviving
members of the Bonaparte line were quick
to renounce their claims to the imperial
crown that was with one exception the
year before in 1831 Louie Napoleon's
older brother Napoleon Louie had been
carried off by an outbreak of measles
that meant that the chance to become
Napoleon the third it passed straight to
Louie Napoleon his mother's prediction
had come absolutely true and he was the
heir to the French Empire
[Applause]
so here's the thing about suddenly
declaring yourself Emperor of France it
doesn't actually make you Emperor France
trust me I've tried that is not to say
that Louie Napoleon's claim unlike mine
was not totally empty there was still a
large contingency of burnup artists in
France looking to revive the Empire
France itself it was also unstable in
July 1830 the three glorious days that
toppled the restored Bourbons and put
the July monarchy on the throne while
June 1832 had seen another attempted
revolution against the July monarchy
this time involving a lot more showtunes
it wasn't hard to imagine their force
and charismatic leader with the buda
part name rallying the people of france
to his side and overthrowing the
government sadly though louie napoleon
was not that man you see Napoleon the
third he was a weird-looking guy a
member of his entourage once described
him as a small man with a long hat face
broad drooping shoulders a fat torso and
very short legs he walked slowly with
his feet pointing out and his body
tilted to the left side
he was also puffed up he was pompous he
was prone to prancing around in military
regalia although he was said to be
charming in private Europe at large
regarded Louie Napoleon is something of
a clown and the thing is here he kind of
was a clown take the Strasbourg coup as
an example on October the 3rd 1836
living opponent tried to seize control
of France by walking into a military
garrison in Strasbourg ins rallying the
men to his cause instead the garrison
commander had all of the mutineers
arrested and Louie Napoleon was deported
to America not that the Exile lasted
very long though in August of 1837 queen
Hortense fell seriously ill Louie
Napoleon caught the first book back to
Europe to be at her side when she passed
away on October the 5th rather than
return to America in the wake of his
mother's death
Louie Napoleon instead went to London it
was while in the British capital that he
cooked on boneheaded coup attempt numero
deux by 1840 the July monarchy it was
unpopular looking to prop up his support
King Louis Philippe arranged half
Napoleon Bonaparte's remains reinterred
in Paris's Loserville eat across the
channel Louie Napoleon mistook the
celebrations for a sign that the French
were crying
for another Emperor Bonaparte so on
August the 5th 1840 rounded up a gang of
56 mercenaries and staged a landing at
balloon samara the plan was that the
site of Louie Bonaparte would inspire
the population of France to revolt and
overthrew the July monarchy and then
hoist Louie Napoleon up onto their
shoulders and declare him Emperor of the
French they instead the Emperor was once
again promptly arrested the coup of 1840
was so flagrantly incompetent that it
probably saved Louie Napoleon's life
Legion order debats wrote one doesn't
kill crazy people one just locks them up
the July monarchy well they agreed
rather than death Louie Napoleon was
condemned to life imprisonment in harm
fortress near arms despite his
insurrection repast Louis Napoleon's
imprisonment it was actually kind of
comfortable yet a large library and was
allowed to read and write at his leisure
he wound up learning so much that he
took to calling the prison the
University of arm he even managed to
write and publish a book the extinction
of poverty which was almost Marxist in
its treatment of the poor the book
became a surprise bestseller in France
and earned Louie Napoleon a strong base
of support amongst the workers by 1846
though Louie Napoleon had grown tired of
home University on May the 25th he
escaped by dressing as a laborer and
simply walking out the door he
resurfaced in London a few days later
and went back to his impotent ku
plotting by now the self-proclaimed
Napoleon the third was almost 40 and
said nothing but to failed coos to his
name
it would take a spectacular turnaround
for Louie Napoleon to fulfill his
mother's dreams and become Emperor the
entire social order of France would have
to be exploded like a volcano had just
erupted underneath it little did anyone
realize this as the 1840s drew to a
close a volcano was exactly what France
was sitting on
earlier how back in 1830 the July
monarchy came to power in France on the
back of a revolution well in 1848 it
exited in exactly the same way on
February the 22nd 1848 a governmental
ban on people meeting for banquets
somehow span off into violent street
protests this in turn somehow led to
King Louie Philippe abdicating the
monarchy being abolished and the second
French Republic being declared that
happens on February 26th this was the
moment Louie Napoleon had been dreaming
off not two days later on February 28th
he arrived in Paris and offered the
revolutionary provincial government his
help and recurringly paired the
provisional government said to properly
back into exile yeah France might have
revolted but it was not a revolt aimed
at putting a Bonaparte back into power
the new Republican government they
wanted liberal reform not some bumbling
clown pretending to be as famous uncle
but Louie Napoleon wasn't as stupid as
his enemies thought back in England he
settled down to watch events unfold just
biding his time and he didn't have to
bide his time for very long On June the
23rd 1848 the workers Paris revolted
against the provisional government who
felt that they had betrayed the
revolution the result was the June days
a three-day massacre which saw 1,500
Parisians being killed when he was over
the Second Republic it's still stood a
bit those connected to it were now even
less popular than the July monarchy had
been now all of this it that Louie
Napoleon in an excellent position on
September the 17th to the 18th 1848
France held elections for the
Constituent Assembly Louie Napoleon got
on the ticket in 1/5 departments and
with that the assembly was forced to
lift his exile now legally back in
France Louie Napoleon began campaigning
energetic Li for the upcoming
presidential elections he ran as an
outsider populist promising extinction
of pauperism to the poor military
discipline to the burnup artists and the
president's untainted by the June days
to everyone else the results on December
the 10th 1848 were a landslide Louie
Napoleon Robert home with 74% of the
vote the elites they were left gasping
in his dust
this clown was now president still his
opponents comforted themselves with the
knowledge that the new constitution only
allowed presidents one four-year term by
president lui Napoleon it be gone I mean
after all it's not like he had a habit
of launching coos or anything like that
right Louie Napoleon's motivations
though they revealed themselves slowly
the self-start prince presidents at
first worked with the National Assembly
supporting populist moves like sending
the military to Rome to protect the Pope
from revolutionaries in fact things went
so slowly that nobody even seemed to
notice the way that Louie Napoleon was
stuffing all the key posts in
governments and the army with loyalists
kind of just like someone plotting a
coup might do in 1851 Louie Napoleon
finally came into the open with his
ambitions he asked the National Assembly
to amend the Constitution to let him run
again they said no so the Prince
presidents when they got rhythm December
the second is a special day for
Bonaparte ists it's the day that
Napoleon was coronated in 1804 it's also
the day that he defeated the third
coalition at the battle of Austerlitz in
1851 it also became the day that Louie
Napoleon finally did a coup right
overnight 30,000 army loyalists occupied
Paris people awoke to posters announcing
the National Assembly had been dissolved
although some diehard Republicans men's
the barricades it simply wasn't enough
on December the 4th 1851 Paris fell
president Bonaparte announced the
effective dissolution of the Second
Republic then held a referendum just to
check that this was cool with everyone
and it totally was he won with an
enormous margin ten months later in
November of 1852 he held another
referendum on restoring the French
Empire and giving himself near unlimited
power and yes he won that too on
December the 2nd 1852 the first
anniversary of his coup Louie Napoleon
was officially crowned Napoleon the
third emperor of the second French
Empire this is what the famous Karl Marx
great about history repeating itself
actually refers to first as tragedy then
as farce but what did Louie Napoleon
care it finally done it
had achieved the impossible dream that
his mother had set for him back when
they were both living as Axel's
well it'll laughter him I did one now it
was time to show them just how wrong
they were
what does a guy who's been lusting for
power for basically his entire life do
when he finally gets it in the case of
Napoleon the third the answer is well
everything that once the period of 1852
to 1860 is known as the authoritarian
Empire and it's the period when a poll
in the third ruled like a mad cross
between a total despot a liberal utopian
and a kid on a sugar rush running around
trying to do a bazillion things at once
his biggest project was Paris at the
time the City of Lights was actually
more like the city of horrible smells
and oh my god what's that floating in
the sin the French capital was filthy
cholera outbreaks were common the
streets were crowded slums everything
you probably picture as Paris in your
mind today is exactly what the city was
not in 1852 one of the Emperor Napoleon
the thirds first act was to call
architect Baron Haussmann into his
office and tell him to go forth and
bring in air light and cleanliness
together the two men they wrote the
Paris tree plan of today they knocked
down slums built parks improved
sanitation gave every worker a home
created the sweeping boulevards that
Paris is famous for those elegant
buildings that pop into your head
whenever you hear Paris well this is
when they first appear it's also when
Paris first gets its nickname Hussman
installed so many gas street lights that
the capital was christened the city of
lights
still the potently in the Third's reign
it wasn't just construction work he made
education free and compulsory he lifted
the ban on women gaining higher
education he instituted public pensions
and ushered in agricultural reforms that
wipes out famines in France permanently
he also made the state invest heavily in
railway and steamship building and opens
lines of guaranteed credit to small
business owners it was almost like a new
deal of the 1850s or maybe an old New
Deal and it totally worked by 1870 the
economy was growing at 5% a year while
industrial output had boomed by 75%
in short the clown turned out sir not
really be a clown at all Napoleon the
third even managed to grab fronts and
choice colonies like New Caledonia
acquired in 1853 Vietnam 1858 and
Cambodia 1863 now
we certainly shouldn't gloss over his
authoritarian side while France boomed
economically socially it transformed
into a police state
there was censorship restrictions on
Association and free speech and there
were spies everywhere
and then there was the rather sticky
topic of war the period from the end of
the Napoleonic Wars until the rise of
the second French Empire it hadn't seen
a single conflict between Europe's great
powers barely was Napoleon the thirds
throne warm from his Imperial backside
than the Crimean War erupted in 1853 now
the Crimean War is super complicated and
it would be unfair to blame it all on
the Poli and the thirds but he was
itching for a fight and he pressed
forward where maybe others would have
backed down the result was a conflict
that killed nearly a million people but
left France and her ally Britain newly
victorious on the European stage this
confidence boost led in turn to Napoleon
the third getting involved with Italy's
second war of unification in 1859 given
Italian nationalists had tried to
assassinate him the year before
throwing a bomb at his carriage that
killed 14 of his entourage you might
have expected Napoleon the third to
fight against unification but no he sent
the French army to help the kingdom of
Sardinia kick the Austrians out of their
Italian colonies they won that war too
which is why nice and Savoy are
currently part of France by 1860 Louie
Napoleon was riding high as Napoleon the
thirty and really made France great
again it also convinced himself that he
was a tactical military genius on par
with his legendary uncle it even found
time to marry countess Eugenie de
montijo you know what they say about
pride it always comes before a fall and
so Louie Napoleon he was a legendary
fool
historians of the second French Empire
called the period after 1860 the liberal
Empire why well it's the period when
Napoleon the third pivoted from being a
nasty despot to a slightly more cuddly
one the transformation came in 1860 to
head off a political crisis over the
huge loans his projects were racking up
Louie Napoleon offered his Senate new
powers and east censorship the changes
were enough to keep him in power and led
to more liberalization down the line yet
all this is really just a sideshow to
the two major events of 1862 the first
was something of a private problem Louie
Napoleon's reign had been partially held
together by his boundless energy but in
1862 he developed exceedingly painful
bladder stones that sapped his energy
and left him reliance on those around
him the second was far more
consequential for world history and that
was the rise of Otto von Bismarck we've
actually got another vine graphics video
in the works about Bismarck so we're not
going to get too sidetracked with him
right here but just let me give you a
very quick overview Bismarck was the
minister-president of Prussia and
Germanic country roughly analogous to
modern eastern Germany and northern
Poland's with its capital in Berlin
Bismarck was a firm believer in both the
strategic use of warfare and the
unification of all the many German
statelets
into a single Germany he was also a
political genius who didn't take fools
lightly which was a big problem for
Louie Napoleon not that tiny Prussia
appeared much of a threat to France in
1862 when Bismarck went to war against
the Danes in 1864 Napoleon the third
barely even noticed in October of 1865
Louie Napoleon even promised the iron
Chancellor that France wouldn't
intervene if Prussia went to war with
Austria less than a year later these
seven weeks war ended with Vienna beaten
Louie Napoleon actually mediated the
peace talks which oversaw the creation
of a sort of half unified Germany the
northern German Confederation this was a
problem because it was now clear that
this thing called Germany was becoming
extremely big and extremely powerful in
a very short space of time but not only
in the Third's he was simply too
arrogant so maybe to deluded to realize
the threat that Germany post he still
thought that he was the senior partner
in the relationship with Bismarck
it wasn't until Bismarck blocked
French annexation of Luxembourg by
threatening war that Louie Napoleon
realized that it was an over his head
the big trouble was that everyone else
realized it too when France backed off
on Luxembourg Bismarck was able to see
just how weak the French Empire was the
French public they turned on their
Emperor
in the 1869 elections the government
nearly lost control of the Senate by the
end of 1869 Napoleon the third was
forced to fully liberalized the Empire
just to keep power turning it into a
kind of constitutional monarchy
unfortunately the change meant listening
more than ever to what the public wanted
and what the public wanted was war with
Prussia
even by the standards of the 19th
century the causes of the
franco-prussian war are ridiculous
beyond belief in Spain Queen Isabella
abdicated the throne and a Prussian
Prince often take up place France said
no and sent their ambassador to tell the
brushing King to back off the Ambassador
met the King on a walk shouted in / -
and then
stormed off and with that begins the
franco-prussian war alright so it was
slightly more complicated than that
in reality the real trigger was the m's
dispatch which contains an account of
the meeting between the king and the
Ambassador that was perfectly calibrated
to make both sides think that they'd
been grievously insulted it was edited
by Bismarck who by now had decided a
quick war with the French would be the
perfect bonding exercise to seal German
unification and he got his wish on July
the 19th 1870 France declared war on
Prussia the French armies 280,000 troops
they were mobilized
despite being shockingly ill by this
stage and a polian the third rode out to
personally lead the troops amusingly his
staff so sure that they'd soon be
conquering German territory that they
forgot to pack any maps of their own
country the first engagement it came on
August the 4th 1870 and it was a
massacre
the well-trained Prussians made
mincemeat out of Louie Napoleon's
shambolic army for two entire days after
a staggering retreat the French force
again on August the 16th and again they
were wiped out getting desperate Louie
napoleon tried to summon the spirit of
his dead uncle he gathered all remaining
French soldiers for an attack on the
Prussian troops besieged Metz this was
exactly the sort of foolhardy gamble
that his uncle would have made but the
difference is his uncle could have
pulled it off on the 1st of September
1870 the French and the Prussians fought
the Battle of Sudan which could just as
well be called the defeat of Saddam the
French they were pulverized the
Prussians managed to encircle and then
capture their entire army among those
arrested was Louie Napoleon when the
news of their Emperor's capture reached
Paris on September the 4th the
government was so outraged that it voted
then and there to abolish the second
French Empire along with its useless
Emperor France immediately became the
3rd Republic it wasn't the end of the
war though that drags on through the
grueling siege of Paris but for Louie
Napoleon it was done
Louie Napoleon was kept prison
until a peace treaty was signed and the
unification of Germany was declared On
January the 18th 1871 finally in March
the now-former Emperor was released back
into exile in England but his
humiliations they were not done yet
in the wake of France's epic defeat
Paris was seized by a radical
revolutionary group that became known as
the Paris Commune
they ruled for two months before putting
Paris to the torch when the French army
retook the city the new Paris that Louie
Napoleon had spent so long building was
simply burned to the ground although it
would be ultimately rebuilt to his
designs he would never live to see it
over in England Louie Napoleon had
settled in the village of Chislehurst
with his wife and their son who they
still called the Prince Imperial it was
a short and painful retirement Louie
Napoleon's health got worse until On
January the 9th 1873 he went to the
hospital for a last-ditch operation to
cure his bladder stones he died under
the knife at age 65 all of those times
it listened to his mother as a young
excellent dreamed of being Emperor he
could have never imagined that he would
end like this in 1879 lumina Polian ser
the Prince Imperial also died
extinguishing their families line two
years later his wife Eugenie had both of
them re buried in Farnborough a
pleasantly boring town some 30 miles
from London although the tomb that holds
Napoleon the third remains a tourist
attraction
it's hardly less of a lead so what in
the ends did Louie Napoleon accomplish
well he ruled France for longer than his
uncle did and he undoubtedly oversaw an
industrial boom that modernized the
French economy he founded colonies like
New Caledonia that a still departments
of France today and he promoted workers
and women's rights at a time when it was
deeply unfashionable on the other hand
he took France from a peaceful state
back to one of dangerous warfare and
paid a catastrophic lehigh price the
peace settlements after the
franco-prussian war crippled France all
the way into World War one but perhaps
the biggest thing that the other Emperor
Bonaparte accomplished was becoming the
other Emperor Bonaparte this was a man
who as a child was bans from his home
country forced to live in exile and
derided as a clown yet through sheer
dogged determination he managed to
conquer the very system that had locked
him out if only for a brief time was he
a clown was he a tyrant was he a vision
leader let down by one disastrous lapse
in judgment well the jury's still out on
that one
but there's one thing we cannot deny
Louie Napoleon he was and will forever
be Napoleon the third emperor of the
French so I really hope you found that
video interesting if you did please do
hit that thumbs up button below do not
forget to subscribe we've got brand new
videos just like this several times a
week so hit that subscribe button hit
that thumbs up and you'll find out about
all of those if you're looking for
something else to watch though why not
check out my other channel called top
10s you'll find a link to that on the
screen now as well as below this video
and as always thank you for watching
[Music]